bonjour johnny hazzard
secrétaire général du parti progressiste
martiniquais qui est avec nous ce matin
dans son caddie le bilan de santé de la
martinique selon vous selon le prisme
progressiste comment se porte notre île
chérie selon vous et vous ne serez pas
surpris qu'on vous dise que la
martinique est plus qu'à la martinique
recul la situation de plus en plus
difficile aujourd'hui la réalité des
infrastructures tout ce qui a été
construit en termes d'outils a été
détruit par la nouvelle équipe
gouvernante en place exemple sur les
fonds européens exemple sous le tcsp la
voiture a dit que les fonds européens
qu'il y aurait une brusque accélération
des choses vous n'avez entendu vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec lui pas du tout
mais bon c'est facile de le dire quand
aujourd'hui il faut regarder la réalité
des entreprises aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'avoir accès
aux fonds européens parce que le gibier
martinique europerformance a disparu je
rappelle que les fonds européens c'est
des cofinancements donc y ait des
cofinancements souvent des tas de la ctm
et des fonds européens même s'ils ont
l'autorité de gestion et à des passages
obligés avec l'état au en détruisant le
gip et ils se sont retrouvés seuls deux
sont coûte de leur côté on est dans une
relative opacité parce qu'on ne sait pas
alors ils ont obligation de publier la
liste des personnes mais pire on ne sait
pas aujourd'hui que sont les critères
d'attribution donc d'un projet de la
grande aventure lorsqu'il dit que pas du
tout mais l'outil étant et a été détruit
aujourd'hui allez demander aux
entreprises aujourd'hui qu'en fait
déposer des dossiers aussi bien à la 7e
aussi bien au niveau de l'état parce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas simplifié on a
enlevé ce guichet unique aujourd'hui les
choses sont beaucoup plus complexes et
le temps de reconstruire c'est facile de
détruire mais la reconstruction ça prend
beaucoup plus de temps donc on est plus
qu'alarmant au recul et la consommation
des fonds européens aujourd'hui est
extrêmement faible a pris en 2007 a
promis qu'il n'y aurait pas de
désengagement quel autre élément
pourrait être révélateur de cette
martinique qui ne se portent pas si bien
selon vous écoutez le chômage depuis
maintenant janvier il ya des centaines
de personnes qui travaillent à la city a
même un cdi qui ont été licenciés je dis
bien au cdi qui ont été licenciés donc
le chômage est en tout cas de croître
c'est extrêmement grave aujourd'hui sur
le territoire nous risquons une crise
sociale si on continue à pencher de
façon abusive selon les termes de
l'équipe dirigeante actuelle à la cité m
ce sont les termes de l'équipe
dirigeante actuelle qui n'arrête pas de
m'en tire notamment sur le compte
administratif qui n'arrête pas de dire
aujourd'hui est de manipuler des choses
qui ne sont pas vraies donc aujourd'hui
il faut bien comprendre la peau faire
fonctionner il faut un service public
pourra voir le service public il faut
être engagés surtout quand on a un
niveau d'investissement qui a été celui
de la région de l'époque du conseil
général de l'époque je rappelle que
c'est aujourd'hui sur chaque année plus
d'un milliard d'euros d'investissements
inquiet quand vous voulez investir il
faut contrôler même si ce sont les
entreprises qui travaillent et
aujourd'hui on est à 0 investissements
dans le bilan à la fin de l'année de
l'équipe actuelle le transport commun en
site propre
on va s'y arrêter parce que s'il ya
vraiment un exemple de ce qui ne marche
pas et de façon incompréhensible pour
l'homme la femme de la rue c'est bien ce
tcsp
aujourd'hui pourquoi ça ne fonctionne
pas la situation à qui la situation est
très claire aujourd'hui la ctm est
propriétaire de quasiment 90% des
ouvrages donc ne lavent delà du site
propre de la voie réservée du tcsp la
khl à la septième est propriétaire des
feux des feux dans les cas où fo la 7e
ne sait pas utiliser les feux et les
faire fonctionner donc ils demandent à
la ville de le faire mais la ville ne
peut pas le faire si les feux dont la 7e
et propriétaires ne sont pas conformes
aux images il voulait mettre en
conformité si la martinique et qui
entendent ça ce matin est ce un jeu de
ping pong cépages et de la sncm dit que
c'est la cacem key2key qui doit gérer ça
qui a syndicat mixte pour faire
fonctionner ce tcsp etc à la tête de
cette casse est née de ce tcsp il y à
des hommes dansent ensemble pour une
martinique ne sont pas ménagés écrire si
vous me rené dans la manipulation dont
le montant ne faut pas mélanger coco
peas abricots pouvait être propriétaire
d'un appartement aux propriétés caïla
mais c'est un locataire qui vient
habiter dans la maison sauf que le
locataire qui viennent habiter dans la
maison fokine la cliqua et la propriété
apaba le cantal à la clique à l hadopi
moniot les locataires l'arthrite qui
moniot la cft et mettez en place
aujourd'hui le la marche à blanc pour
permettre le coup de connaître le coût
de commercialisation pardon du
fonctionnement du tcsp si aujourd'hui on
ne met pas à disposition la voir il y
avait qui est la propriété de la cité
serait là c'est un plus si serge
letchimy et toute son équipe avait mis
ce tcsp en fonctionnement avant les
élections égouttez politiquement vous
avez certainement raison peut-être que
le tcsp roulera après les législatives
de l'année prochaine en tout cas la
réalité qu on essaie représentative on
va attendre écoutez moi nous ne sommes
pas en direction en gouvernance
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être le jeu que
vous venez d'évoquer là aujourd'hui
parce que si le dcsp où le gars dit que
c'est l'alchimie qui mettait tout bague
à l'an passé que tcsp ak oui sauf que
aujourd'hui ik freinet ipaq à démarrer
mais
simon morin et puis didier la game pas
normal que je crains l'exploitation et
les infrastructures c'est ce que je vous
disais dit le propriétaire c'est la ctm
le locataire devrait être la cft eu et
devrait être le syndicat mixte le
locataire mais le locataire ne peut
faire que ce que le propriétaire
l'autorisent à faire et c'est ce qu'il
faut comprendre que nous attendions un
peu beauf ont cette force non non non
mais ça fait rire tout la marque
qui ne fonctionne pas quelque chose qui
se passe quels que soient les arguments
des uns et des autres
ça fait rire on a un peu ridicule sur la
situation les martiniquais subissent les
conséquences aujourd'hui ça c'était très
cher et ça continue à coûter très cher
de la montre à ce déluge tenu
responsable de ce que le propriétaire
décide ou deux ne décide pas de faire
aujourd'hui ou en tout cas décidé de ne
pas vouloir livrer les infrastructures
dont ils ont la propriété au syndicat
mixte pour que la cft vous savez on ne
prône la main que l'offre nous donnent
la main le relais n'a pas été transmis à
lacassaigne à la cft comment voulez vous
qu'on poursuive le rôle est alors s'ils
voient que l'intérêt général a subi
puisqu'aujourd'hui on aime on paye le
gardiennage on paye l'entretien donc
effectivement il ya de l'argent public
est dépensé vous savez c'est comme le
lycée gaillard et bellevue qui a
accueilli le lycée et chercheurs
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 7 millions de
aux nouveaux de nouvelles dépenses qui
ont été faites simplement parce qu'on
n'a pas voulu terminer les travaux au
niveau de victor rouge nous prenons
cette qualité là d'une chance un autre
problème qu'il faut point en contre
qu'est-ce qui a la compétence et du
chauffeur de taxi aujourd'hui c'est la
ctm haut c'est là où je me dis un vrai
problème si tcsp des cas où les jo dia
là où élever kareo ou bien mao ou
bloquées parce que normalement il
devrait y avoir une connexion que les
chauffeurs de taxi mais les chauffeurs
de taxi si
ça ne fonctionne pas ben oui mais là ça
ne fonctionne pas aujourd'hui la réalité
est que chacun a des prérogatives des
sacs à main des compétences est côte par
jour cet esprit qui ne roulent pas
aujourd'hui ça coûte beaucoup des
centaines de milliers d'euros
aujourd'hui sur le non fonctionnement en
termes d'entretien parce que y'a
l'éclairage il ya tout ce qui doit
servir aujourd'hui sur l'entretien et le
gardiennage notamment du centre
technique des transports qui accueille
jeudi les nouveaux bus fiction des bus
spécial spéciaux par nom des bûches des
bus à haut niveau de service donc cette
dynamique là aujourd'hui est freinée
elle est à l'arrêt vous pouvez continuer
sur ce chemin là moi je pouvais faire
aujourd'hui vous dire que nous assumons
nos responsabilités que nous on la
livraison des infrastructures pour
permettre à ce que ce tcsp roulent le
plus rapidement que possible nous
aurions souhaité politiquement
effectivement et de toutes les façons au
niveau de l'intérêt général que ce tcsp
houle avant la fin de l'année
malheureusement on n'est pas sous ce
chemin là un autre dossier je donnais à
charge durant les vacances se vous
rappelez ya eu cette fête patronale sur
le nord caraïbe à case-pilote rappelé
tout à fait réel font plaisir le maire
avait choisi de mettre à l'honneur alain
huygues despointes c'est un homme qui
avait été décriée suite à ses propos
dans un documentaire sur canal + en 2009
intitulé les derniers maîtres de la
martinique et vous aviez manifestez-vous
ppm vif agacement
puisque rate mon plaisir mettait cet
homme à l'honneur sauf qu'une photo avec
maurice antiste remettant ce même homme
une médaille à circuler ce qui a
provoqué railleries et moqueries vous ne
saviez pas que maurice antiste avait
rendu hommage également à des pointes
vous avez ce qui est grave c'est que
vous journalistes vous a été celui qui a
remis la médaille qui tenait vite et
lui-même de la commune de case-pilote
sous la présidence d'honneur d'alfred
marie jeanne et on ne s'arrête pas aux
propos qui ont été tenus et la mise à
l'honneur de quelqu'un qui a tenu des
propos et au delà du nom et peu importe
aujourd'hui il faut s'élever contre ce
type de comportement dans langage qui va
à l'encontre de l'humanisme qui va à
l'encontre du vivre ensemble qui va à
l'encontre des valeurs quand on voit
fillon qui parle de la colonisation
française comme partage de culture il
faut s'élever et le parti progressiste
martiniquais
déjà à travers deux équipes dénoncé les
propos de françois fillon donc
aujourd'hui le parti progressiste
martiniquais maintient son communiqué
nous ne pouvons pas accepter si nous
voulons vivre ensemble dans un pays
pluriel et diverses notamment la
martinique et en liaison avec la france
nous ne pouvons pas le faire aujourd'hui
en tenant ce type de propos qui rôdent
d'adresser à vous de cette personne et
qui deviennent des vérités et les
aideront dans votre attention à ce genre
de manifestation maurice antiste par
exemple si jamais ça devait se
reproduire ce genre de situation devrait
refuser de remettre une médaille écoutez
c'est une évidence aujourd'hui
maintenant chacun assume avec sa
conscience et sa responsabilité en tout
cas le parti progressiste martiniquais
ne retire rien est ce que nous retenons
aujourd'hui c'est que à chaque fois
quelle que soit la personne quel que
soit le lieu qu'elle se soit ce qu'il
dit dès que ce va cela va à l'encontre
de l'humanisme des valeurs d'éthique et
de moralité nous devons le dénoncer de
façon à redonner à cette martinique les
valeurs dont elle a besoin pour faire
face aux épreuves de la vie au quotidien
de tous les jours la souffrance humaine
est ce qu'elle est il faut trouver des
solutions il faut redonner une espérance
positive année d'élection ruera des
législatives des sénatoriales à johnny
hazzard la coalition ensemble pour une
martinique nouvelle est déjà en ordre de
marche il n'y a pas des risques
d'explosion d'implosion tellement il ya
des personnalités fortes quelles sont
les conditions éthiques quel que soit le
lieu vous allez les campagnes l'ailé les
instituts dans les termes les
investisseurs au campagne aux élections
sont des enjeux importants avec une
ambition collective faute maintenant
nous devons aujourd'hui se respecter
l'alliance a été confirmée par le
congrès du parti progressiste
martiniquais donc nous resterons dans un
goût parce que nous nous sommes
plurielle et nous devons accepter nos
différences d'ailleurs c'est pas pour
rien que le parti progressiste
martiniquais se bat pour le doigt la
différence dans le respect de l'égalité
des hommes et des femmes donc
aujourd'hui nous verrons nous avançons
petit à petit oui nous serons notre deux
manches je rappelle simplement que les
élections ne sont qu'un moyen de mettre
en place des projets et que nous oui
mais a beaucoup d'ambitions personnelles
au delà où tout le monde n'a pas que de
l'ambition personnelle ya des personnes
savez la politique se nomme je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de donner le
sentiment que la politique justement ces
massacres chaque montagne à l'ambition
personnelle il ya des gens vous savez
j'ai démissionné de la cacem chacun fait
pour l'emploi et le demandeur oui oui
oui oui ça c'est vrai nom pour respecter
les statuts du parti progressiste
martiniquais parce que la loi ne me
l'impôt et pas il faut bien longtemps il
faut bien le comprendre la loi ne
l'imposé pas révélé ça devenait un peu
cette de nous la casse
était toujours de détourner la situation
quand vous savez aujourd'hui que le
meilleur moyen de redresser cette
société est de redonner la personnalité
collective au sens noble du terme à
cette martinique c'est de faire en sorte
que l'exemple et l'exemplarité viennent
d'en haut donc oui nous élus nous devons
donner l'exemple et autour des valeurs
d'éthique et de moralité de
responsabilité du manis merci d'avoir
été ce matin avec notre johnny je
rappelle que cette secrétaire général du
parti progressiste martiniquais bonne
journée